breaking news
11 Uhr heute morgen eine Grundschule in
Aachen
cdu-kanzlerkandidat Armin Laschet wirft
seinen Wahlzettel in die Urne und wenn
sie ganz genau hinschauen dann sehen sie
zwei blaue Kreuze bei der CDU nun ist es
keine Überraschung dass der
cdu-kanzlerkandidat die CDU wählt aber
die Frage und deshalb ist Jan Schäfer
hier bei uns mit im Studio ist ob diese
Stimme überhaupt noch gültig ist ich
darf mal aus der Homepage des
Bundeswahlleiters zitieren das
Bundeswahlgesetz dort heißt es sie
müssen in der Wahlkabine ihren
Stimmzettel so fallen falten dass ihre
Wahlentscheidung nicht erkennbar ist nur
so kann das Wahlverfahren ordnungsgemäß
ablaufen und das Wahlgeheimnis gewahrt
werden außerdem heißt es das
Wahlgeheimnis ist verletzt sobald der
ausgefüllte und in die Urne geworfene
Stimmzettel einer Person zugeordnet
werden kann das heißt also das
Wahlgeheimnis ist durch Armin laschetier
ganz klar verletzt worden denn jeder
kann sehen wem er seine Stimme gegeben
hat ja Thomas wir haben es hier mit der
ersten wirklich schweren wahlpanne
dieses Wahltages zu tun ausgerechnet
Armin Laschet ausgerechnet der
Kanzlerkandidat zeigt wen RGB das ist
nicht überraschend dass er die CDU mit
beiden Stimmen wird das muss man auch
mal sagen aber du hast es auch gerade
aus dem Wahlgesetz vorgelesen die
Stimmabgabe ist geheim so jetzt die
große Frage was passiert hat Armin
Laschet das bewusst gemacht wir haben
jetzt ein paar Juristen auch telefoniert
die sagen na ja das kann man ihm
eigentlich nicht so richtig unterstellen
dass er das bewusst gemacht hat wir
haben auch die Bilder gesehen es war
jetzt kein Moment in dem man noch mal
den Stimmzettel direkt offensiv in die
Kamera gehalten hat und gesagt hat Leute
guck mal ich habe mit beiden Stimmen
überraschenderweise CDU gewählt nein so
kann man das nicht sagen und wir haben
und ich habe auch gesehen wie er den
Stimmzettel reingesteckt hat in die Urne
das war jetzt eher ein normaler Vorgang
und wir wissen es von Spitzenkandidaten
die ja immer ein bisschen Warten an der
Urne das noch Fotos gemacht werden
können ja jetzt ist das Foto in der Welt
wie gesagt die große Frage wird sein
gibt es jetzt Protest die Wahl könnte
natürlich damit angefochten werden wenn
man das Gesetz ganz ganz streng nimmt
und dann musste genauso ist es so und
dann muss der Bundeswahlleiter am Ende
als letzte Instanz müsste darüber
entscheiden du hast gerade eben auch
gesagt kann man diesen Stimmzettel
nachvollziehen ja er hat ja sehr dick
seine Kreuze markiert das wird
sicherlich eine Sisyphusarbeit in dieser
Wahl suchen aber man könnte natürlich
Uhrzeit wir haben ja durch den
Screenshot der gemacht wurde können wir
genau sehen wir können rückwärts sogar
den Countdown in der bei Bild den wir
rückwärts laufen lassen können wir genau
zuordnen das war ja gegen 11 Uhr 10 gut
man könnte es auf diese Sekunde genau
aber nun ist es so in dieser Wahl ohne
mischen sich ja alle Wahlzettel am Ende
wird die Urne geöffnet und dann wird sie
umgedreht und in der Regel ausgeschüttet
auf einem Tisch so dass man gar nicht
mehr genau sagen kann war das jetzt
jemand der die Stimme um 9 Uhr abgegeben
hat oder war es jemand der die Stimme um
11:26 Uhr abgegeben aber seine Frau
Susanne Laschet die auf jeden Fall ihre
Finger über die Kreuze hält sieht man
hier ganz genau während Armin Laschet
also hier ganz deutlich zeigt ob
willentlich oder nicht wen er gewählt
hat und du hast es gesagt die Kreuze
sind sehr dick das könnte vielleicht
wieder auffindbar sein haben wir gesehen
dass seine Frau Susanne ganz geschickt
vielleicht auch per Zufall auf jeden
Fall ganz geschickt die Finger über den
Wahlzettel hält also ist es merkwürdig
dass überhaupt die man aufgepasst hat im
Wahllokal ich habe heute in Berlin
gewählt und da wurde mehrmals ganz
darauf hingewiesen dass der Wahlzettel
nach innen geklappt werden muss also
dass man gerade an der Wahlurne auch
nicht sieht was gewählt wurde was man
selbst gewählt hat ist auch gar nicht zu
sehen ist welche Parteien dort antreten
also erwartet wird nach innen
zusammengeklappt ähm und deswegen ist es
durchaus bemerkenswert das auch niemand
in dem Wahlbüro also nicht der Chef
dieses Wahlbüros oder andere Beteiligte
gesagt haben Herr Laschet sie müssten
eigentlich ihren Wahlzettel anders
feiern sie haben es auch falsch gemacht
als wir als wir live kommentiert haben
haben wir noch darüber gesprochen dass
es sehr sehr lange dauert als Armin
Laschet noch mal die Unterlagen vor
zeigte am Ende bzw die letzten
Formalitäten da erledigen musste saß er
hinter an saß ein Mann hinter einem
Schalter hinter einer Plexiglasscheibe
ich weiß nicht ob man das am Anfang des
Videos auch gesehen hat und sie haben da
wirklich zwei Minuten lang noch
verbracht und wir haben die Zeit noch
hier versucht zu überbrücken das heißt
da hat jemand noch mal richtig drauf
geguckt ja das ist komisch also es ist
in der Tat so es wird heute ganz ganz
genau darauf geschaut alle
Personen die wählen gehen heute wir
haben es bei Armin Laschet auch gesehen
und jeder der heute ins Wahllokal geht
der muss natürlich eine Maske tragen das
heißt auch wenn man seinen
Personalausweis noch mal zeigt dann gibt
es da erhöhten Druck auch noch mal genau
hinzuschauen der ganze Prozess dauert
heute deutlich länger als normal aber
natürlich wundert man sich wenn der
Kanzlerkandidat kommt und dann also noch
mal richtig genau befragt wird von
denjenigen die im Wahllokal ihren Dienst
tun ist das jetzt besonders gewissenhaft
gewesen gab es halt noch andere
Unstimmigkeiten wir sind auch gerade
dabei das zu klären aber vollkommen
richtig der Hinweis man hätte das auf
jeden Fall sehen müssen und den
Kanzlerkandidaten noch mal darauf
hinweisen müssen denn jeder weiß wenn
Armin Laschet die Stimme abgibt dann
sind natürlich alle Kameras auf diese
Wahl ohne gerichtet das weiß Armin
Laschet auch aber noch mal es ist jetzt
nicht überraschend dass er zweimal die
CDU wählt hat ja noch viele viele
Anzeigen auch geschaltet gestern in den
Zeitungen und
Radiospots also die Überraschung nicht
über die Frage wird sein wird dieses
wird die Wahl möglicherweise angefochten
wird seine Stimmabgabe angefochten muss
vielleicht am Ende sogar der
Bundeswahlleiter entscheiden er hat
möglicherweise eher aus Versehen getan
als bewusst und wenn wenn auch aus
versehen Verstoß gegen das Wahlgeheimnis
so viel kann man jetzt schon festhalten
und ausgerechnet Armin Laschet
ausgerechnet auch noch auf dem
allerletzten Meter es war ja nicht die
erste Panne wir haben vorhin ganz kurz
eingeblendet gesehen wie Matthias
Brügelmann und Marcel Reif schon warten
die sind bereit und wir berichten hier
den ganzen Tag natürlich für Sie meine
Damen und Herren an diesem historischen
Tag über die Bundestagswahl aber jetzt
machen wir uns erstmal locker mit den
beiden Sportlern
en geworden
[Musik]